welcome to part four in our series on
grounded language understanding our
topic is varieties of contextual
grounding what i'd really like to do is
make connections with additional tasks
as a way of drawing out what i think is
one of the central insights behind the
work that we're doing which is that
speakers should try to be informative in
context let me explain a bit more about
what that means so our task is this task
of color reference in context the
speaker is given three color patches one
of them designated the target and the
speaker's task is to communicate which
of the three is the target to the
listener who's in the same context but
of course doesn't know what the target
is
and what i think you see running through
the human data here is that speakers are
striving to be informative in context in
this first case the speaker can just say
blue because the contrasts are so clear
but in the second case merely saying
blue would be really unhelpful it would
be uninformative in the context because
there are these two blues and as a
result the speaker is pushed to do
something more interesting the darker
blue one making implicit reference to
the context in an effort to communicate
effectively with the listener
and that communication aspect i think
can be so powerful and runs through lots
of tasks both ones that explicitly
involve communication and ones that
involve a more general setting
one case of the latter is i think
discriminative image labeling which is
tackling this lovely paper mao at all
2016. the task here is given an image to
label entities that are in those images
and for many many contexts it would be a
shame if our goal was to label these two
entities here and we simply called them
both dog it's uninformative in the sense
that it doesn't distinguish the two
entities in the context of this picture
what we might hope
is that we would get fuller descriptions
like a little dog jumping and catching a
frisbee and a big dog running fuller
descriptions in the sense that they
provide more detail that distinguishes
the two dogs
and we could extend that to full image
captioning as well again given these
three images it would be a shame if our
image captioning system just labeled
them all dog
we might have the intuition that we
would like the image captioning system
to produce descriptions of these images
that would help a listener
figure out which image was being
described and we might have as a further
goal for this image captioning system
that as we change the set of distractors
it's sensitive to that and produces
different descriptions
trying to be informative relative to
these new contexts that we're creating
amplifying some kinds of information and
leaving out other kinds of information
to the extent that they would help the
listener achieve that task of figuring
out which image was being described
machine translation is another area that
might benefit from this notion of
informativity and context this was
explored in a lovely paper by ruben
cohen gordon and noah goodman in 2019
so let's say our task is to go from
english to french
reuben and noah just observed that at
the time these two english inputs she
chopped up the tree and she chopped down
the tree were both mapped to the same
french translation
which is a shame given how different
those two english inputs are in terms of
their meanings what we would like is to
have the english inputs mapped to
different french sentences
and their intuition about how to achieve
that would be to achieve some kind of
invariance so that given the translation
from english to french we should be able
to do the reverse figure out from the
french
which underlying english state was being
quote referred to in this context so
it's language on both sides but it's
drawing on this idea that we want
translations that are informative in the
sense that they would help someone
figure out what the original system
input was
same guiding idea drawing on this
metaphor of communication but now to
achieve good translations
and in other domains it's just very
intuitive to think about informativity
in context so daniel freed at all they
have a lovely paper exploring how to
give navigational instructions drawing
on pragmatic ideas like informativity
and context
and for example they have both speaker
and listener agents and they observe
that the base speaker is true but
uninformative whereas their rational
speech speaker which brings in pragmatic
ideas
is more sensitive to the kinds of
information that a listener would need
to follow an instruction and the same
thing is true on the listener side the
base listener is unsure how to proceed
but the rational mr englishman was able
to infer that since this instruction
didn't mention this couch over here it
was probably not relevant to the
instruction and therefore this listener
stops at this point in interpreting the
navigational instructions
and stephanie talks and colleagues have
explored this idea in the context of
human robot interaction they've called
their second their central mechanism
inverse semantics and this is again just
the intuition that a robot producing
language ought to produce language that
reduces ambiguity for the human listener
in this context here where the robot is
trying to get help from the human it
shouldn't just say help me the human
won't know how to take action but it
also shouldn't do something simple like
hand me the leg the robot should be
sensitive to the fact that there are
multiple table legs in this context and
the robot needs to ensure that the human
listener is not faced with an
insurmountable ambiguity and that would
therefore push this robot in being aware
of the listener state to produce
descriptions that were more like hand me
the white leg on the table fully
disambiguating from the perspective of
the listener
and i'd like to push this idea of
informativity and context even further
by connecting with one of the classic
tasks in machine learning which is
optical character recognition even this
task i believe can benefit from notions
of contrast and informativity in context
on the left i have four digits and you
can see that this is a speaker who puts
little hooks at the top of their ones
and slashes through their sevens and
those two pieces of information would
help us disambiguate the final digit and
infer that it was a one
on the right here we're pushed in a very
different direction this is a speaker
who does not put hooks on the top their
ones or slashes through their sevens and
that would lead us to think that this
final digit here is a seven notice that
in terms of what's actually on the page
these two digits are identical
but the context is what's leading us in
very different directions we can assume
that some fundamental level the speaker
is going to be informative in the sense
that they're going to write in ways that
are consistent and draw intended
contrast between their digits and that's
what guides us toward what are
ultimately the correct classification
decisions even for this apparently
mechanical seeming environment